especially in a four-hour class when you
have nothing prepared you go to some
dark places
yo I'm CT I was a fourth and fifth grade
teacher for two years in the Los Angeles
Unified School District and you are I am
a Dan I was an adjunct professor at an
art school I'm Samantha Jun teach
special ed and now also substitute
teaching pre-k through 12
my name is Salani and I'm a science
teacher and today we are gonna play some
never have I ever regarding teacher
experiences never have I ever taught
without a lesson plan flying without a
net freestyling it Wilin totally it's
exhilarating and sometimes those are
like especially in a four-hour class
when you have nothing prepared you go to
some dark places you start talking about
German Expressionism Wow end up with
like okay so but 9/11 wasn't never have
I ever had a romantic relationship with
a teacher at my school in fact I have
not but I do know that I can get it I
have not that I wanted to but judged
parenting skills
oh my god yeah what are they doing what
are they doing do homework with your
children talk to them about what's
happening in class go over those
assignments with them and make sure they
do their homework or even with them read
with hello like right well everyone is
just trying their best right but then
you also like wonder to yourself like
what elaborate emotional house of cards
have you constructed within this student
that makes them behave the way they do
and obviously like parenting is so hard
just like the parents are probably
judging us as teachers we're most
definitely gonna judge than its parents
misplaced idealism and things that
either aren't important or that are evil
yeah yeah it's it's terrified gossip to
other teachers about a student
I wouldn't say gossip that's a strong
word like vented AB
solutely and they all been to the both
the same students alright and wanna God
you know I want to figure out why you do
what you do
oh you experienced a stone it's not what
you do yeah support yeah yes it is like
if a students making you feel bad I'm
sure they're making all the other
teachers feel bad I found for sure yeah
have you ever forgotten students name
absolutely and unfortunately it's
usually the ones who are like really
well yeah a good kid you forget such the
beginning of the school year and they're
all like nine years old they all kind of
look at the same MO same haircut same
clothes and Nike t-shirt they're all
named David you know what I mean you
know everybody's a david gone to class
hungover I have not I don't have like my
old hangovers I either have I find the
next day or I am scream vomiting it was
a bad situation I was in a rough spot in
my life it was not pretty and I'm not
I'm not proud of it but I made myself
get up and go to work so that's good
right um never have I ever cried at work
all the time crying right now
no way no I'm sorry yes yes I'm kind of
worried it was a thread of work for me
it was a little girl and she happened to
be black and she was mixed and she came
up to me and told me she was like I want
to be like you and I grow up you look
just like me her my hair is naturally
curly and she's like your hair is just
like mine
and I want to be just like you when I
grow up and like just to tears just came
out I couldn't help myself I've never
had students find you on social media
there it is yeah yes and it's a weird
block yes immediately it's like too much
whiskey and we're
once I leave campus I'm not I don't
really post anything on social media
that gives any sort of detail about what
my internal life is that's why I feel
like a lot of teachers don't like don't
necessarily want to live in the same
district where they work yeah because
they don't want to like run into
students they don't want to run into
parents they just want to keep it very
separate had a class watch a movie
because you didn't feel like teaching
absolutely yeah but I was also teaching
film classes so it was completely [ __ ]
seems like an excuse to me I just do
what the teachers tell me to do and I've
had teachers giving me lesson plans and
also tell me to just let them watch the
end of the year when we're doing like 5
million things and I don't have a
teacher's assistant
oh we're watching movies yeah I mean it
was also I was just like I can't do it
today it's just one day on Friday yeah
I've had a favorite student abscess yeah
yes and they know who they are they know
who you are absolutely yeah every year
yeah the kid came up to me to talk to
you about 30 minutes after class about
super 8 millimeter films like you're my
favorite there's not so well-behaved
students become my favorite oh yeah the
troublemakers sometimes are the favorite
never have I ever caught a student
cheating I mean of course I definitely
yes cut students doing I'm sneaking a
few things it's rampant it's rampant
been bullied by students no yeah strikes
kids are brutal I don't think it
necessarily call it bullying or just a
complete disrespect I don't know what it
is about the phones and high schoolers
but like they're so attached at he just
became like very rude and like straight
up just said to my face like no and then
he like left the room and you have to
like not show any fear just like like
beady eyes just be like what you know
like you can't let him know graded
assignments without really checking him
there's a one-timer it looked good
nobody had a discrepancy so I think it
was pretty on point I actually have not
if I have one job it's to do that listen
if they just if they even turned in a
piece of paper with writing on it just
say it's good okay we got okay
yeah that's definitely b-plus you know
what I mean failed a student on purpose
no I would never do that no I've never
especially if you don't like a kid
you're like go on you pass get out of
here if you did that then it's like
what's the what's the point of even yeah
here yeah I already have enough going on
in life I never have I ever run into a
student outside of school yes I'm sure
it's just a passing thing like I was
walking in a direction they were walking
towards me and they're just like hey and
I'm like hey and then I look at their
parent and then we just keep walking so
it's like yeah hey I know your kid right
I don't know you want my child I'm like
oh it's nice to see you it's something
that makes me happy but I also like you
know want to keep moving on never have I
ever had a crush on a parent I have not
but I know a parent that had a crush on
me
I taught college age kids right so I
didn't ly have much contact with their
that would have been weird
I had to block them on social media
enough it was not cute solid no leash
that was fun playing never have I ever
yes like if there's one big takeaway
teachers are people we have emotions
just like you we cry just like you we
laugh just like we obviously are human
and I make mistakes
we do things that we shouldn't yeah
everyone's just trying to get along
we're just trying to get by but at the
end of the day we love your kids yes and
we work really hard at what we do you
know we'll be there
[Music]